something incredibly disturbing happened
to the ancient Egyptians and in this
video I'm gonna share with you the
mounting evidence that a cataclysmic
event killed off the ancients that
predate the dynastic Egyptians for
example I'm going to discuss a destroyed
pyramid but many who have visited the
site and have studied megalithic
structures for their career have
described as looking like it's been
blown up or even an entirely new pyramid
discovered just a few months ago that is
in ruins and buried under the sands of
Egypt what on earth would it take to
destroy a pyramid or even take the bent
pyramid for example as I'll discuss what
on earth would it take to put a huge
dent in a pyramid or how about what
would it take to knock down a 100-foot
1000 ton statue could it be more than
just an earthquake I mean take for
example the colossi of memnon which I'll
also discuss why on earth do they have
incredible scorch marks on them when
they're made and carved out of one solid
piece of quartzite and the quartzite
melts at 3,000 degrees Fahrenheit in
fact they're finding sites throughout
Egypt that have unusual scar and
charring marks on the stones which are
just unexplainable is it possible that
this all ties into a little known fact
that the Mideast is covered with melt
glass and the only thing that could have
done this is atomic explosions or cosmic
events such as airbursts or cosmic
impacts and I'll be discussing that in
just a moment let me start off by
discussing the destroyed pyramid of
Jeffrey located in a burger wash which
is approximately eight kilometers north
of Giza mainstream archeologists have no
explanation for this and why it's been
destroyed they describe it as the top
half of the pyramid is just completely
missing and is nowhere to be found
they speculate that the stones after
being destroyed was quarried and used
for something else and that perhaps
Jeffrey the Pharaoh was disliked and the
essentially well literally turned his
pyramid into ruins but when you look at
these photos here something tells me
that it was far more than just a mob of
angry ancient Egyptians with bronze
pickaxes I mean even take a look at
photos of the internal structure I mean
this thing is just clearly something
incredible happened to it and just to
clarify if you
seen the documentary the pyramid code
which I highly recommend you can find it
on Netflix or YouTube this site is not
the same one that I described in a prior
video about the unfinished pyramid of
Zayat LR Yan which is the one that the
Egyptian authorities have since turned
into a trash dump as I described in that
prior video but no this is not the same
site that was in that documentary or
visited by Brian Forrester who I'll
discuss in just a few moments in fact
they're 10 miles apart and they're two
totally separate locations and they have
unique features of themselves but
clearly there's a lot of similarities
here as well but speaking of Brien
Foerster I highly recommend that you
subscribe to his channel he is going to
the field far more than any mainstream
archeologists I mean I can't say that
for certainty he hasn't said that but he
goes to dozens of megalithic sites
throughout the world many countries
places you never even heard of and he
shows you firsthand through awesome
video tog Rafi the all the evidence
incredible details that have been left
out of the textbooks and this is the guy
that inspired me to look into the topic
of ancient human civilization so you got
to check him out and take a look at
these screenshots that I took from one
of his videos where he shows you these
debris fields as well as these unusual
char marks located on stones throughout
ancient Egypt so definitely go check him
out now like I mentioned earlier in the
video they found an entirely new pyramid
just a few months ago in March of this
year and I actually made a video on this
but it's worth discussing again this was
covered by every single major news
outlet throughout the world and although
there's so few photos of the site so far
because they're still excavating it the
one thing that's absolutely incredible
it was not even mentioned or discussed I
should say in these articles is the fact
that it's in ruins why on earth are they
finding destroyed pyramids buried under
the sands of Egypt because again what on
earth would it take to destroy a pyramid
and why are the mainstream
archaeologists and Egyptologists not
making a bigger deal about this I mean
that's an incredible thing for a pyramid
to be destroyed is it not and that
brings me on to the bent pyramid
mainstream will tell you that this
pyramid was a design flaw that
essentially the Egyptians were
transitioning from the Step Pyramid over
to the traditional-looking pyramids and
they simply screwed up but there's so
many things wrong with that theory I
mean clearly you can see here that the
dent in it or the design flaw as they
call it happen
halfway up so why didn't they stop fix
the problem or just move on to something
else altogether why did they bother
finishing it and not only did they
finish it they went ahead and laid all
the limestone casing stones throughout
the whole thing top to bottom why bother
doing that if you had already ruined the
pyramid from the get-go is it possible
that this is evidence of a major
cataclysmic event and that reminds me I
have to correct myself from my prior
video where I stated that the mainstream
states that the Step Pyramid of Dozier
came after the Pyramids of Giza that's
not true at all in fact they state that
it was the very first pyramid but the
point that I was trying to make is that
there are approximately 88 0 known
pyramids throughout Egypt and obviously
they keep finding new ones but the Great
Pyramid of Giza was built seventh
according to mainstream archeologists
and Egyptologist so after the Pyramids
of Giza were completed there's about 70
73 other pyramids that were built after
and when you look at these you'll see
that none of them compare whatsoever
from the precision and sophistication to
that of the Pyramids of Giza
so the question again is why is
technology regressing why are the best
pyramids the earliest ones I should say
now let me move on to the massive statue
located at the Ramesseum nearly 100 feet
tall and weighing estimated more than
1,000 tons what on earth would it take
to bring this thing down I mean I
suppose an earthquake is a completely
logical explanation but just take a
second to look at this thing I mean the
feet themselves are up to my chest and
just to put it into comparison the
Statue of Liberty although taller weighs
in at 225 tons so compare that to 1,000
tons but is it possible that some sort
of cataclysmic event brought that thing
down I mean look at the colossi of
memnon like I mentioned earlier 60 feet
tall weighing 720 tons of piece carved
from one solid piece of quartzite what
on earth would it take to burn that
thing quartzite melts at approximately
3,000 degrees Fahrenheit
so I mean guys this this is something
far more than some gasoline dumpster
fire by an angry mob I mean just look at
this thing something incredible happened
to it and I made a video on this it's
one of my earlier videos and by the way
this stone the closest site they have
where quartzite could have come from is
about 200 miles away so how on earth or
why on earth would they
something so big and so heavy this far
but going back to the evidence of a
cataclysm why are we finding vast
amounts of milk glass throughout the
Mideast from Libya Egypt Syria in this
all coincides with the same exact
timeframe of the Younger Dryas impact
boundary which is found for more than
three continents and I would say that
Africa now applies for continent number
four so what on earth would it take to
do this either an atomic bomb which I am
just that's not where my bet is on or an
asteroid cosmic impact or an airburst I
mean we all remember the airburst had
happened over Russia in 2013 which
injured 1500 people and caused an
incredible amount of damage and that was
equivalent to about 30 times that of the
strength of the Hiroshi no bomb now when
we compare that to the Tunguska event
from 1908 that flattened more than 800
square miles of old-growth forest we're
talking trees 150 feet tall with
incredibly deep roots and every one of
them practically was leveled and even
the evidence is still visible more than
a hundred years later and that by the
way discipline in comparison registered
at more than estimated 1,000 times
stronger than a her own Obama is it
possible that's some sort of massive air
burst an air burst from hell happened
over ancient Egypt and just destroyed
that civilization altogether clearly
something incredible happened over Egypt
at some point in time and I highly
recommend you look into the works of not
just Brian Forrester but Graham Hancock
Randall Carlson Robert Bauval John
Anthony West Christopher Dunn Stephen
Mailer I mean there's so many people
that have inspired me to look into this
subject so you have to look into these
people because I'm still learning new
things every day so if this subject
interests you definitely look into these
people but I'm gonna leave it at that
I'm Jimmy this is bright insight like
and subscribe and I have many other
videos to come on a whole wide variety
of topics take care everybody